[Music]
steve oh hold on let's go around the
circle don't just just don't we'll start
with you though you're the hot seat okay
that's what they call it now
wait a female type yeah what's your
female type yeah i was curious to know
because you're mr proximity master the
search we did earlier as far as my porn
searches he likes equator girls pacino
adventures yeah
uh
very reasonable granny cream pies granny
cream peppers
all these old ladies from the equator
it's just
the whole spectrum so on tinder do you
even have an age limit or you're just
like let's go
i don't have a lot of luck on tinder i
uh the i got scammed twice on it like
catfished like for money yeah oh [ __ ]
and uh yeah buy it from russia like they
were dudes what's the hustle yeah what's
the move
well okay
i matched up with i mean and when i
matched up with this particular woman it
was like it was one of those things like
oh there's too good to be true because
she looked like a super like model from
like
easter you know like happened to my
buddy too yeah so i'm like oh you know
and then like she had pictures of her
djing and so i'm like hey and then i
started talking to her and then slowly
she was like
oh are you working and what do you do
you know she was trying to like she was
she's just trying to get her poking out
yeah she was poking and then she was
like
i'm sorry to bring this up but
uh
because there's an emergency i go what's
going like and she's like oh well
there's a family emergency like
we need money you might and she started
saying that her like grandfather her
like her family she wants to bring from
europe to the states and if i have money
like it got scheduled why don't you go
i'll meet up with you and i'll give you
the money yeah who are you talking about
no it was a scam yeah the second one was
worse
out did you send money
no okay
no you said you got scammed wait wait
wait brother you we thought you got
scared oh i i'm sorry let me read this i
was waiting for you and then i'm in line
at western union steven let me rephrase
stephen i almost got scammed okay but
the second one was even worse because
again it was i got matched up with a
woman that she was way out of my league
eastern european yes but check this out
so do you know
i somehow trans we we got on instagram
you know i'm like hey what's your and i
was foolish right you're supposed to
stay on that the tinder site but once i
was on her instagram simultaneously
another third account
started texting me while i was talking
to the tinder girl
and the this other message was
a missing person's report from like
berlin
germany of like this
this girl that's like that wasn't even
the age of the girl i matched up with on
tinder and it was like a black and white
like a passport picture of the one i
matched up with oh [ __ ] uh you know like
some like yeah it was like a weird
parallel [ __ ] yeah it was like some sort
of extravagant like scam setup thing
you know isn't that weird and so what
did they say so the message was like hey
are you did you have are you talking to
her like i'm looking for her like
you're like have you had you know this
person that i'm talking to from tinder
what'd you say yeah i've been bathing no
i just
i don't know block block and just sweat
oh just like oh i would have been
curious you don't like to play with the
scales yeah i like to play with that i
don't what do you mean play no i don't
play with them every time
i want to hear how steven every time i
get the call right they do that call
from the call center you know what i
mean and it's always like hey your
social security got hacked big time and
big time
you better call our operator and i hit
the number every time and then i go and
then the best thing right because they
go hello i'm with the social security
administration i'm like you are a
[ __ ] scamming piece of [ __ ]
he's like listen to me you [ __ ]
little dick [ __ ]
i'm steve green i got a big old dick no
they immediately started talking she
dropped the social security thing and
just started
[ __ ]
mad at seeing that
like the most unprofessional thing ever
like they completely give it away so you
break that character i break the cut i
knock them right off the [ __ ] game
yeah it's the best dude so you play
along with it no i immediately am like
you scamming piece of
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
don't know what you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] the kids copies what you said
country are they from normally oh indian
always that was india right now every
time what is that why kick my dog [ __ ]
you kick my dog
your [ __ ] bench
they're so pissed but it's the best
because it starts off super professional
oh yo you'll kick my dog [ __ ] your help
we are the social security try it it's
really fun i need to start doing that
yeah so let's go around the room then
how do you guys deal with this guy i
don't know what's your type though oh
yeah his question back to this question
what's your type oh yeah everything
supermodels mainly whoever likes it from
serbia
whoever likes me i like that you know
why you should answer this question is
because there might be your soulmate
watching right now dude we're not doing
any of that right now
we already tried they already tried to
do a dating game at uh king and the
sting and how many people are getting
their dms that want to date you why are
you better than zero why are you better
than [ __ ] fans why won't you [ __ ] the
fans they want to [ __ ] you i [ __ ] a
lot of fans
there's probably tons of fans i want to
[ __ ] you they should call that app only
fans before me i want to know what he's
talking about
what
what is going on
so tell me the secret dude i need to
learn your [ __ ] [ __ ] your fans
dude no wait i mean i'm talking to mr
miyagi right now now daniel russo what
is going on master sensei sensei
miyagi-san please show me the way so you
they message you
and then they say
you want to hook up
and you say yes
that's it he's not pulled in my leg no
he's not [ __ ] down he's not [ __ ]
pulling you're like this whole [ __ ] no
no but the thing you're an og in the
game so you know what i mean jk has you
have way more views and more of a i
guarantee you if you went down your list
of who's following you there's gonna be
my podcast is a cult
it's like i bet you there's a couple of
cute girls man let's just regardless
regardless let's just have a moment of
honesty and vulnerabilities off the
record like nobody's to see us literally
off the right it's oh we can separate
whatever we want so if you just
genuinely open up and talk about what
your type is on like a romantic interest
level who knows what might happen
you're already getting zeros anyway
white latina colombian
indian
why is it start there this was like i'll
go for grannies big asses
a person i like anal girls who are like
a wife i would like to say that i didn't
say animal bees i didn't bring up anal
i've never used that word today every
type of person buy honey
by honey [ __ ] d-gen dude that wasn't
the authenticities guys i thought that
was fair yeah that's a start okay what's
next
but you're gonna say you like all of
them so they must all be in your
proximity what i'm saying
is
all of them are in one room you only get
to choose one describe that one that you
chose
like is she every [ __ ] type of girl
is in the room yeah yeah i like ones
with like they have their like own style
you know and it doesn't have to be like
the most popular style it could be
something unique to them okay that's
cool okay so a little freaky i like that
what kind of style like god like no just
like uh whatever makes them the best
it's their own style it is he's right
there like a cheerleader
want my god no i wouldn't muck off i
wouldn't narrow the playing field i'm
trying to narrow the playing field yeah
i'm trying to imagine like a joke in
[ __ ] high school what are we doing
asking joe for joe's at hot topic like
she's in student body
there's only two in high school
she's the treasurer
oh my god class secretary dude
you guys are two sides of the same
[ __ ] corner i give up you guys just
take it away
no i'm trying to learn from you dude so
too you're the same side of the [ __ ]
coin they just don't know it yet no no
let me continue my cuz i forgot okay
it's different for you guys because you
guys are like a pr like your platform's
big you have a lot of views you know
what i mean we're stripping all that
away you're just in a room of every
[ __ ] possibility parts of disbelief
he's like i don't think that's true i'm
like people have been [ __ ] fans when
they have like a thousand followers
an italian
okay
or dirty blonde girl wait now that's a
different person
don't just laundry list everything you
like i'm just gonna have to have
everything i mean just like me so so
peacock like bees yeah bees okay these
are that's respectable bees
bees besides physical what else like
he's like hey titan i don't want to hang
out with
wait am i i feel like i'm like speaking
it differently am i answering this
incorrectly you're talking about like
[ __ ] somebody
and we started out with what's your like
relationship yeah yeah yeah
i need to correct this before it gets
out of hand past second grade
[Laughter]
they don't have to be religious they
don't have to be religious
right okay
they could even come from a divorce
family a single parent
stepsister see i'm doing this wrong as
long as they're a good person they have
a good heart they don't you guys start
somewhere yeah yeah so they're they're
not lying
they're not liars no liars they're
honest people dj's okay yeah djs are
fine uh
yes someone with yeah someone with their
own musical they don't follow the trends
they're unique they're unique they they
like what they like they like major yeah
yeah yeah exactly oh yeah oh yeah like a
girl who likes bjorn i like new york how
did you get with your previous
girlfriend edamanchi was that a show
well you're banned yeah the band yeah
she was a groupie you are a fan [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you're a fan [ __ ] for show
well
was it like a mutual friend that's
different and that was like just a rare
event that just happened to have your
mind it's rare because check this out
that night we performed was this the
finale of uh game of
thrones so
that was a 50 50 because most people
stayed home that night i'm surprised you
didn't stay home i know
but she happened to go
so that's not even a fair because you
have a star you're a star you're a big
time star guy yeah i like i like i like
the series but any other questions about
that
wait wait so when you're you're
performing and then you talk to her she
talked to you yeah she came up to me and
that's my problem like my last few
girlfriends i never pursued them oh
while you guys were dating what's wrong
with that
how's that a problem dude they come to
you that's not very manly though i think
that's the guy's duty to take an
initiative uh that would be that would
be unfair to the world we live in
because girls have the equity to take
that as well i think that's i don't
think that's completely fair
i think it's back and forth yeah
whatever yeah but you think now like you
meet mostly on social media right would
you at least agree um
a lot of people need to work instagram
could be used as a dating course would
you agree with that that's what sliding
in the dms is about baby
okay so i have in the pa i'm not like
you guys like i've had once in a blue
moon i've talked to girls on dms okay go
how was that not like us well you guys
probably talked a lot more than like he
was saying that he has a lot of
experience he's an anomaly
what are you typing he's married he's
married he's married and i'm engaged so
i i think maybe it's not as crazy as you
think i was with my chick before all the
internet dating stuff took off so i'm
like following you as far as knowledge
is there so it just means two peas in a
pot i have a girlfriend now so it's just
me
steve's an excellent wingman by the way
hey dude i got i got this guy's back all
the time
in what ways are you looking like how
are you he did a dating show with me on
my channel i did a dating show with him
on his channel yeah and every single
girl that came on he asked he said would
you rim joe and then they're like yup on
his channel you could do a dating show
on ig live holy you can do it right now
no
the only reason because this is that i
thought about this because they did it
on king mustang and i appreciate it but
like i could tell that
if they were really interested in me
they would hit me up on my instagram and
not for the show exactly sure they did
it to get on camera huh you know which
is why we're not bringing on anybody now
we're just we're just trying to honestly
hear
what you like
if you're interested in getting laid my
man's got laid off with that [ __ ]
straight up off of what off of doing the
live show english meeting i did a couple
dating shows online and
yeah it was fun you did
and you some success some success yeah
so tell me about an example
[Laughter]
we did a live show we were sifting
through people we were here
i was i was hosting
one of the main things that he likes
sexually is getting his ass eaten so the
first question that i had
first the first so how does that make
you feel i like you even more
i got that from your brother i like you
i said it he's a sexual maverick dude as
he coined
no so the first question i would ask is
do will you eat joe's ass or would you
toss a salad and if they said no i said
get the [ __ ] out of it
how many contestants it was like 10 yeah
then how did you sift through all that
they would go so then after when the
show is over i would then go okay it's
time to go to joe's dm that's the only
place to go here's how to leave the show
you got to go in the chat message me and
then
yeah the winner flew over
to my house and we hooked and we hooked
up right away yeah it took some time no
dinner just boom pretty much
so you open the door hi mm-hmm he's like
hey i got nugs in the oven and then yeah
they're doing it 30 minutes yeah really
so what types of what kinds of women did
you meet through this
asians
no i'm not i'm just interested i'm
interested i'm interested no it's
actually very diverse right
it was like let's talk about it it was
hispanic there was white there was
um black there was yeah i think there
was it was pretty mixed chinos
here's what i think you're missing and i
mean this genuinely go ahead
you're looking at the the dating show
that you're on and you're going they
only want to be here for this one well
look at it like it's a first date you
don't know how it was fun after a first
date they had fun with it with joe and
then if they liked joe from that
interaction like cool i'll go to the dm
and that's it's the first interaction
bro remember
you hit a home run every time you didn't
go first base second like it just went
oh to be fair if there's 10 people on
show and he's only hooking up with one
he it's like he failed nine times i
think they're just shutting herself down
too early yeah and also don't think so
outcome-based yeah and don't just don't
think about sex so much and then you get
sex you know what because my mind is
corrupt what's so corrupt about the porn
yeah reverse engineering you do the porn
with them now that's the way we we solve
this equation yeah i need to learn to
reverse
engineer this golem the goblin mine the
the problem here is you're already
talking about you got to do the day you
got to do that and then you get laid but
if you think that going to in and out
will end to sex
it's not even sex it's like in and out
cream pie those are like the two
terms
they're two separate they're very local
they're both very low
they're two different things man and and
the thing is if you've been chatting
with someone for so long you could build
it up to where they're so horny and by
the time you see each other it's on it's
on like tron yeah because my my kirk my
current girlfriend right now less than
15 minutes of meeting her we took a
shower together because it's called take
a shower with her because it's corona
but you shampoo you're saying because
it's corona like everybody's still
supposed to understand by the way yeah
yeah because it's corona the first 15
minutes we had to disinfect each other
so we jumped in the shower dude you're
the [ __ ] man
you know what i'm saying
he's touched his dick all day with this
hat
no joe's got mad underrated you think
about joe though you are my sensei dude
the thing about joe is he's a good
[ __ ] time man whoever i thought you
were gonna end that [ __ ] yeah he's like
good [ __ ] too i bet you got a good penis
too dude
be honest dude you do don't you yeah
dude
you don't got no rice dick dude there
ain't no stick in there yeah that's like
eight egg rolls connected
no no no no no no no no no i know you
got girth i could tell no no no no no no
don't do that you do
you do
you do don't you that's cool arguing for
like five minutes
you got girth will you at least admit
you have girl i don't know
i've never seen another man
no no this is my next question i never
seen another man's hard dick
just show me yours after i'm off camera
yeah yeah you've never done orgies with
david cho
cause he does crazy like sex adventures
right no no we we had fun back in the
day but that was like a long time ago we
did one like vegas trip we had so yes
did you get
whatever why don't you do it anymore you
guys got bored i don't do that anymore i
just you know because i like jerk and i
like that you like it more than girls
yeah i just sometimes it's it's like the
lazy person's excuse like uh just jerk
off i like intimate sex too but because
the hooker sex is like boring yeah it's
not there's it's empty isn't it yeah
yeah it's empty you're a romantic dude
man you gotta tap into that
you gotta tap into your romanticism you
know yeah
or like don't like look at the person
and think to yourself cream pie is like
the end goal only yeah
do that on the third date right
or or just wait for that to later like
if anything feel free to think about in
and out first that's cool i'm down with
that but sometimes it could just end
that in and out because you're just
getting to know each other yeah yeah you
eat in and out so much you're just
trying to get into these people in and
out honestly take the burger out and
leave the in and out in
you're going to get to the crib ever
thought about just trying to get to know
someone
to make her seem like i'm some kind of
robot like
sex cream pie snacks that's a good robot
shake cream pine kiss boobs you know no
i'm not like that oh that's just what
you represented for 20 minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you